Personal subject pronouns.
Those pronouns,
which can be said
Vulgar Latin and romance languages also use pronouns for a person impacted by
the action English.
These are object pronouns with verbs.
These typically sit immediately to the left of the verb in romance.
Bj's,
you seen maybe dates.
You see me
when an action impact someone directly,
a Latin accuser pronoun bike may or Dang,
he's placed before the verb,
maybe that
Davy dead,
the first and second person,
plural.
Objects are null and void.
Third person objects come from the accuser tubes of Ila and Ila Lov days.
You lovey this,
he loves be days
plural.
Them derives from the nominative elite,
an elite in eastern romance.
Italian livedo live here though
verbs
that impact their object indirectly like to me in says to me,
have an indirect object pronouns to the left.
In modern romance,
these are mostly identical to the direct object pronouns.
Maybe see
me,
Dj and so on.
The difference does become apparent in the third person.
We're data forms are used.
Instead dative case elite to him or to her
led cove
or dative Ilise to them at least [inaudible]
vulgar Latin actually used the date of forms and other persons for indirect
objects,
a difference that still survives in Romanian,
maybe debt [inaudible] with a direct object Midi Kit mz che with an indirect
object.
When a verb can take both direct and indirect object pronouns,
they both still fall to the left of the verb.
Dk says,
Midi Kit says to me,
Lou di Kit says it.
Mulu decayed,
says it to me.
or.gives d.
Dot gives you lost.
That gives them the loss that gives them to you.
These object pronouns often trail non finite forums,
particularly infinitives dkt Lou to say it to you,
Spanish the teeth,
Italian Dda Tello,
but notice that French and Romanian keep them on the left
when a verb has the same subject and object.
It's called reflexive,
reflexive objects in English have an ending self like I see myself.
Romance languages use the same pronouns that you've learned as reflexives.
Vivid.
Yeah,
Devi this.
This is considered reflexive.
The exception is again,
in the third person where say means herself himself,
itself or themselves.
[inaudible]
so much for object pronouns,
with verbs,
prepositions,
small particles that relate time or space like under or two or beside are
followed by a different set of pronouns.
These are stressed and mostly resemble the subject pronouns I'd knows to us.
I did a lot to her,
but me and you are different.
Amit,
Lamina or
d
romance.
Personal pronouns can be objects of verbs and a preposition.
Now you have a taste of how they do that.
Yeah.